in this video I'm gonna help you prepare
for your geometry final exam so this is
the second semester of geometry if
you're interested in the earlier topics
check out my video that I did for the
geometry midterm I'm going to have
timestamps in the description below so
go down there if you want to hop to a
particular type of problem that you
maybe don't remember from your geometry
class but let's get into this video and
I'll show you how to work through some
of these different problems that you'll
likely see on your exam so question
number 1 says solve for X ok so this is
kind of an easy problem it's a right
triangle and we know that when you have
a right triangle you can use what
Pythagorean care right so again a quick
refresher a squared plus B squared
equals C squared a and B are the two
sides that make up the right angle those
are called the legs but one across from
the right angle that's the longest side
that's the hypotenuse so in this case
what we have is 3 squared plus 9 squared
is equal to x squared so we simplify
that we get 9 plus 81 equals x squared
or you could say x squared equals 90 and
then what you want to do is you want to
take the square root of both sides but
remember when you simplify radicals you
can split this up into square root of 9
times square root of 10 square root of 9
is a perfect square that's 3 so an exact
answer here is going to be 3 square root
of 10 ok so let's go to question number
2 now just a quick note if any of these
concepts are challenging you kind of
forgot about them you can go over to my
Mario's math tutoring YouTube channel
page and over there what I have is you
just type in you know what type of
concept you're looking for and it'll
take you to those videos that I've done
on these exact same topics so this one
says which is not a Pythagorean triple
okay now this is a good question now
what exactly is a Pythagorean triple
well Pythagorean triple means that all
three sides of the triangle are integers
so that means they're nice round numbers
there's not any decimals fractions
they're nice round integers values and
they satisfy this equation here a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
the Pythagorean theorem now the ones
that come up most commonly and these are
the ones that you're gonna want to
memorize are the 3 4 5 the 5 12 13 8 15
17 and 7 24 25 okay now these are ones
that come up the most commonly it's
because these are the ones that have the
smallest integer values but you can
multiply these by
a costume so for example if I multiply
this by two I get six eight ten and look
right there that's the first one so I
can see that this is a Pythagorean
triple meaning if I take six squared
plus eight squared it does indeed equal
ten squared so this does form a right
triangle but we're looking for the one
that's not a Pythagorean triple now look
at 14 48 and 50 well you can see that's
taking this one multiplying everything
by two so that's not one how about this
one three four six I don't see that one
here I've got three four five let's test
it out so we've got three squared plus
four squared
question mark six squared does it equal
six squared let's see that's 9 plus 16
which is 25 does that equal 36 no it
doesn't so that means this is not a
right triangle that's the correct answer
but let's just check this last one
really quick
8150 170 you can see they're taking this
Pythagorean triple and they're
multiplying everything by 10 so that
forms a right triangle okay so it's
definitely an important concept
Pythagorean triples now number three is
the triangle right acute obtuse or not a
triangle given the sides five six and
nine well the first thing we want
understand is that you know the triangle
inequality theorem okay so what is a
triangle inequality theorem well the
triangle inequality theorem says that if
you add any two sides of a triangle
together they have to add up to more
than the third side if they don't you'll
have a drawbridge situation like this
where say for example this side is like
10 and this is 3 and this is like 5 you
see even if you were to fold these down
they're not going to be able to span
that distance of 10 so any two sides
have to add up to more than the third
side right so let's check that first so
5 plus 6 is 11 that's more than 9 5 plus
9 is 14 that's more than 6 9 plus 6 is
15 that's more than 5 so we know that
this does form a right triangle now the
next thing we want to look at is is C
squared greater than a squared plus B
squared is it equal to or is it less
than now which side is C 5 6 or 9 will
the longest side that's our C side so
that's going to be 9 so what we're
testing here now is is 9 squared blank 5
squared plus 6 squared so it's like I
took the Pythagorean theorem and I
flipped it I put the longest side here
on the left okay so if we simplify that
we get
eighty-one this is 25 and 36 which is 61
right 81 is greater than 61 so what does
that tell you it tells you that this is
obtuse okay if it's less than then it's
acute if it's equal it's right now what
we'd like to kind of remember it is you
know take a look at a right triangle
like this so if this is your C side this
is your a side and this is your B side
this form is a right triangle
but what happens if you were to like
open this side see like longer and
longer it's kind of what is it going to
do to this angle across here it's going
to be opening opening opening this is
going to become larger than 90 degrees
can be obtuse whereas if C squared was
less than a squared plus B squared this
is gonna be closing down like this it's
gonna make it less than 90 it's gonna be
acute okay and of course if it's equal
then it's gonna be right so this is a
good question because it tests us on you
know whether it's right acute or obtuse
and also test us on whether it forms a
right triangle or even a triangle at all
okay using the triangle and equality
theorem so let's go to question number 4
which side links don't form a triangle
okay so we're back to our triangle
inequality theorem again
so we're basically if it's going to fail
I'll give you a little quick hint if
it's gonna fail if it's not going to
form a right triangle it's the two
shorter sides that are not going to add
up to more than the longest side so we
can save some time by just saying oh 3 &
4 those are the shorter sides 3 plus 4
is 7 that's more than 6 so this is going
to form a right triangle and we're
looking for which ones don't
okay so this one does 2 plus 3 is 5 but
that's not greater than 5 it has to add
up to more than 5 so this one actually
does not firm all right not a right
triangle but a triangle at all again if
I was to draw a picture here's 5 here's
two here's 3 see how it folds flat 2
plus 3 just barely spans that distance
of 5 and then over here 15 plus 20 is 35
that is more than 30 so this one does
form a triangle so the best answer here
is letter B okay now number 5 what we're
talking about in this question are the
special right triangles the 30 60 90 the
45 45 90 these are really important
triangles to to know and I'll just show
you real quick here this is what you
want to memorize okay so you've got when
these two sides are 45 45 90 these two
angles are the same
this is a right angle this is an
isosceles triangle so meaning that these
two sides are going to be the same so
let's just call these axe and axe and
then the one across from the right angle
that's the hypotenuse that's going to be
x times the square root of two so a
quick refresher if you know this side
you automatically know this side if you
know this side you automatically know
the side because they're the same it's
isosceles but if you want to get to that
hypotenuse you want to multiply by the
square root of two now you might be
saying Mario well what do I do if they
give me the hypotenuse well then you
divide by the square root of two to get
back to the leg okay so that's pretty
straightforward so let's do some of
those first so you can see here if this
is eight then here X must also equal
eight and y must equal eight square root
of two that was easy let's do a bit more
challenging one so now letter B they're
giving us the hypotenuse so to go from
the hypotenuse back to the leg we're
gonna divide by the square root of two
hmm what's ten divided by the square
root of two well we don't want the
square root of two in the denominator so
what I have to do is rationalize okay by
multiplying by root 2 over root two
that's like multiplying by one right and
square root of 2 times square root of 2
is square root of 4 which is 2 and then
you can see the 10 and the two reduce
and we just get 5 square root of 2 so
that's going to be y that's also going
to be X because they're the same
now notice some of the notations that
I'm writing here so you notice how I
didn't even write the angles I just put
these marks well if these two angles are
the same and this is a right angle these
are automatically 45 degrees right so
just a quick refresher there now for C D
and E we're looking at the 30-60-90
special right triangle and this is what
you want to memorize here if you don't
remember this from earlier in your class
it's X X square root of 3 + 2 X ok so
the idea is is that the side across from
the smallest angle the 30-degree angle
that's your short leg that's going to be
X the one across from the medium angle
the 60-degree angle that's your longer
leg that's x times the square root of 3
and the one across from the writing well
that's the longest side that's the
hypotenuse that's 2x so just a quick
refresher if you have the shorter leg
it's pretty easy you just have to double
it to get the hypotenuse or x squared of
3 to get the longer leg if they give you
the hypotenuse that's pretty easy you
just divide by 2 to get back to 1x
that's a shorter leg and then multiply
by square root of 3 to get to the longer
leg the tougher one is if they give you
the longer leg you have to divide by the
square root of 3 and then double to get
to the hypotenuse so let's take a look
at these examples so if this side
for what's this site over here where we
have to multiply by square root of 3 so
this is going to be 4 root 3 and then
here we have to double it so this is
going to be y equals 8 okay let's go
over here to letter D so here they're
giving us the hypotenuse that's the 2x
side so to go back to the 1x side we
have to divide by 2 so that means that X
is equal to 6 and then to get through
this longer leg we multiply by the
square root of 3 so that's 6 square root
of 3 last one here letter e what do we
do to get from the longer leg to the
shorter leg we'll remember we divide by
the square root of 3 so this is going to
be hmm let's see we divide by square
root of 3 now remember you don't want
that square root in the denominator so
what I'm doing here is I'm rationalizing
by multiplying the top and bottom by
square root of 3 which just will give
you square root of 9 and square root of
9 is 3 and then 9 and 3 reduced so this
just comes out to 3 square root of 3 and
then if we double it that's going to
give you 6 square roots of 3 so again
review the special right triangle so if
you need to and let's go on to the next
question okay so if you're enjoying this
video share it with some of your
classmates some of your friends so they
can get a better score on their geometry
final 2 now let's go to number 6 here so
here we're getting into some
trigonometry and all trigonometry means
is it's a trig witches triangle and
Metra you know the measurements and
triangles whether it's the size of the
angles and so here what we have is we
have a right triangle okay with sides 8
15 and 17 we want to find the sine of X
the cosine of X tangent of X then we
want to find the sine of Y cosine of Y
and tangent of Y now the key thing to
remember here if you've forgotten is
that so
Kaah Toa acronym right so the sohcahtoa
acronym means if it's the sine you take
the opposite over the hypotenuse cosine
the adjacent over the hypotenuse and the
tangent the opposite side over the
adjacent side the nice thing about this
acronym is it's always the second letter
divided by the third letter okay so it's
easy to remember so let's take a look at
sine of X so sine of X means that you
position yourself or you stand at this
vertex this angle ax and you say well
hmm the sine is what opposite over
hypotenuse so opposite means a cross
over hypotenuse which is one across from
the right angle so that's going to be 8
over 17
and you got it how about the cosine of X
cosine of X is adjacent over hypotenuse
so it's adjacent that means next to okay
but not the hypotenuse so next to that's
this one over the hypotenuse which is
across from the right angle so that's
1517 right and then the tangent of X
tangent is opposite over adjacent so
opposite is across the Jason is next to
so that's 858 15th right 8/15 okay now
we're gonna switch positions we're gonna
put our little guy over here at angle Y
okay so you pretend like you're at this
vertex this angle and sine is what its
opposite okay over hypotenuse so that's
15 over 17 cosine is what adjacent okay
next two over hypotenuse so that's 8
over 17 and then the tangent is opposite
over adjacent so that's 15 over 8 and
you got it so just remember your
sohcahtoa acronym okay now number seven
it says find x and y okay and they give
us this triangle so again what I like to
do is I like to think about you know my
perspective I like to position myself at
the angle so I'm over here at 42 degree
angle and I'd like to figure out okay
what trig functions sine cosine or
tangent two ties together the opposite
side and the hypotenuse we can see
opposite and hypotenuse that's sine so
what I do is I say sine of 42 degrees is
equal to the opposite over the
hypotenuse then all we have to do to get
X by itself is do the opposite of
dividing by eight multiply both sides by
8 and it's going to be eight times the
sine of 42 now let's get our calculators
out eight sine of 42 it's about 5.4 if
you round to the tenths okay so that's
going to be about five point four and if
you want to solve for y you can do
adjacent in hypotenuse so we're going to
do cosine of 42 equals adjacent over
hypotenuse and again instead of dividing
by eight we're multiply both sides by
eight we get eight cosine of 42 and
let's see what that is approximately
okay that's about five point nine okay
so that's the idea with this one a lot
of times students will say well once I
find this side can I just do the
Pythagorean theorem and you can the only
downside to that is that if you make a
mistake here you're going to then make a
mistake on the next one the other thing
is is that if you round here you could
get a little bit of a rounding area if
you keep rounding rounding rounding so
sometimes this better district
to the original numbers if you can and
work with those because those are exact
values you're going to get a little bit
more accurate answer ok now question
number 8 it says the angle of depression
is 20 degrees which expression can use
to solve for each so they give us this
figure here ok now a quick review of
angled elevation angle depression
remember elevation is like this like
elevation you're like elevating you're
looking up okay so you're looking up
that's your line of sight from the
horizontal depression is what it's like
you're looking down from the horizontal
okay so what I like to do with these
problems is I like to go like this
making them into a rectangle okay and
elevation is going to be up from the
horizontal depression is down from the
horizontal but one thing that's
interesting is that these two angles are
equal to each other because they're
alternate interior angles remember you
learn that in the first semester and you
can also think of this as H and this is
a hundred because this forms a rectangle
okay so it says that the angle of
depression is twenty so that's this guy
here remember these are the same so
that's twenty and twenty what trig
function ties together this angle this
side and this side
well again remember if we position our
guy right here we've got opposite and we
have next two adjacent so that is Toa
that's the tangent so this is going to
be the tangent of twenty degrees equals
opposite over adjacent and if I multiply
both sides by 100 to get H by itself I
get 110 20 and you can see that's going
to be letter B is going to be the best
answer for that one so here it's like in
calculator ready form sometimes they do
that on final exams just so you know to
give you some multiple choice options
and makes it easier for your teacher to
grade right okay so number nine it says
find out what this side is your X okay
so again we're doing more trigonometry
we position ourself at the angle or the
vertex where the angle is 55 and we say
what trig function ties together
opposite and adjacent we're back to
tangent again so what do we have here we
have tangent of 55 degrees equals
opposite over adjacent multiply both
sides by four and you can see it's going
to be four times the tangent of 55 let's
see what that is really quick and you
can check make sure I'm right five point
seven okay so that's the approximate
answer for this missing side now
sometimes I'll just give you a quick
I note here sometimes what'll happen is
you'll have tangent of I'll just say 23
degrees and you'll have like for over a
something like that what I would do in a
situation like this is I would think of
this as being divided by 1 and what you
can do is you can cross multiply so you
could say 8 times the tangent of 23
equals 4 times 1 then you just have to
divide to get a by itself so I hope
you're enjoying this so far if you're
preparing for the AC T or the SAT which
you know geometry plays a big part in
that
check out my two courses my huge a CT
math review video course or my huge SAT
math review video course I've got three
free lessons that you can take a look at
and get a head start with that and if
you're interested you can go on and get
the course a lot of students have taken
it they've told me that it's boosted
their score on the exams and I'm sure
you'll benefit too so check those out if
you're interested in individual private
tutoring whether for your math class or
for a final or to prepare for these
important a CT or SAT Math sections you
can reach out and contact me I'll have
my contact information in the
description of this video but let's keep
going with this video and make sure you
do well on the final exam for geometry
okay question number 10 it says find the
measure of angle X okay so we're still
working with trigonometry here about
what we're doing in this problem is
we're solving for the missing angle so
whenever you're solving for the missing
angle you want to use your inverse trig
functions like sine inverse cosine
inverse tangent inverse so what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to say
what trig function ties together
opposite and hypotenuse opposites across
hypotenuse is across from the right
angle well we know that sine right so a
sine of X equals 4 over 9 but to get the
angle by itself what we have to do is
take the sine inverse of both sides so
we get x equals sine inverse of 4/9 or
some people that are watching this video
know it as arc sine okay so x equals
arcsine of 4/9 or sine inverse of 4/9
let's go to the calculator on that line
and see what we get so sine inverse of
4/9 I'm getting 26.4 degrees so that's
going to be the measure of that angle
right
right there okay let's go to number 11
now now number 11 it says quote solve
the triangle now what does that mean
when they say solve the triangle well it
means you want to find all the sides
the angles it means you've completely
solved it you found everything okay so
when we look at this triangle we can see
it's a right triangle we have two sides
we can find the third side by using
Pythagorean theorem right so we've got a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
where I'm going to say five squared plus
9 squared equals a B squared right so
this is 25 plus 81 which is how much
let's see 25 plus 81 which is 106 right
so that's 106 equals a B squared but we
don't want a B squared we just want a B
so we're gonna take the square root of
both sides now let me just see really
quick so this is actually not going to
be able to be simplified at all so we
can just leave this as an exact answer
square root of 106 and that's that side
right there now we want to find measure
of angle a and the measure of angle B
well again what I think I mentioned
earlier in this video is that if you
want to solve for the missing angle
you're going to have to do you know the
sine inverse cosine inverse tangent
inverse but what you might want to do is
go back to use the original figures that
they gave you if possible to get a more
exact answer so what I would do here is
I would say opposite and adjacent that's
tangent I want to solve for the missing
angle so let me use my tan inverse or
you could think of it as the arc tan a
lot of teachers say it that way so let's
do the arc tan 5/9 check my work on this
I'm getting about 29 degrees I'm
rounding a little bit here but 29 okay
so that's angle a but if you want to
find angle B now we know all the angles
in a triangle add up to 180 right but
because this is 90 that means these two
angles have to add up to 90 they're
complementary so if I do 90 minus 29
what does that come out to 61 degrees
and you got it so you solve the triangle
so that's a good question on number 12
they're giving us now we're switching
from triangles to quadrilaterals quad
means four right and in a quadrilateral
all the angles add up to how much and
triangles add up to 180 quadrilaterals
they add up to 360 right so all we have
to do now is recognize that when you see
this square that means it's a 90-degree
angle
these are adding up to let's see 248 so
that's 248 so all we have to do is say
360 minus 248 which
how much let's see that's 112 so 112
degrees okay let's go to number 13 it
says find the interior and the exterior
angle of a regular decagon now what does
it mean when they say regular well
regular means that all the sides are the
same all the angles are the same that's
what regular means and decagon is like
decade ten years in a decade that means
there's ten sides so there's a couple
different formulas we can use here one
formulas we can use 360 divided by n
that's the measure of the exterior angle
and a regular polygon or we could use
this formula n minus 2 times 180 which
gives you the sum of all the interior
angles but if you divide it by how many
you have that'll give you the measure of
the interior angle so two formulas you
might want to write down and memorize
but let's use this one here first so
let's see so basically a 360 divided by
10 since it's a decagon would give you
an exterior angle of 36 and if we want
to find the integral we can use this
formula but I'm going to show you a
shortcut see take us a simpler polygon
to draw like say for example like a
hexagon see if you know the exterior
angle the one on the outside how much do
you think that into your angle is gonna
be well see how they form a straight
line they're supplementary they're a
linear pair that means if you take 180
minus 36 that's going to give you the
interior angle in this case it's going
to be 144 but you can double check your
work with this form if you want I find
this one to be a little bit easier but
they'll both work okay number 14 it says
given parallelogram ABCD find x y&z okay
so now what they're testing us on we've
kind of moved over to quadrilaterals in
this section but we're talking about our
parallelogram so just a quick review
this is what you want to know about
parallelograms the opposite sides are
congruent the opposite sides are
parallel right the diagonals bisect each
other they cut each other in half the
opposite angles are congruent and the
consecutive angles are supplementary
meaning the ones that are next to each
other add up to 180 degrees so those are
some of the properties about
parallelograms and so here what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say well let's
see opposite angles are congruent so
that means this whole angle this whole
angle are going to be equal so let's
make an equation and solve
why so 3y plus 12 equals 120 subtract 12
that's 108 and divide everything by 3 y
is 36 right so that's gonna be y okay
now let's go to X so now here you can
see these diagonals they're cutting each
other in half that means that this
portion and this portion must be equal
to each other so let's set these equal
so we've got 2x minus 4 equals x plus 8
subtract X from both sides right that's
going to give you X minus 4 is equal to
8 add 4 to both sides and you get x
equals 12 ok that's good and then let's
see Z the opposite sides in a
parallelogram are congruent so I can set
these two equal to each other so let's
see so that's going to be what let's
write it over here we've got five Z
minus 2 is equal to 3z plus 8 3z plus a
so if we subtract 3z from both sides we
get 2 z if we add 2 to both sides we get
10 if we divide by 2 we get Z equals 5
and you can double check your work by
putting it back in you know this would
be 25 minus 2 is 23 15 plus 8 is 23 you
can see that they they're congruent ok
question number 15 it says for what
value of x is the quadrilateral a
parallelogram so remember you know one
of the properties of parallelograms is
that you want the consecutive angles
meaning the ones right next to each
other one after another not the opposite
angles but the ones next to each other
you want those to be supplementary so in
this case you can see 115 plus X has to
add up to 180 which means that X must be
65 and what's interesting is that if
these are supplementary that means that
these lines are parallel okay because of
that consecutive interior angles
Congress theorem and then if these are
adding up to 180 because 115 plus 65
that means that these two sides are
parallel by the consecutive interior
angles Congress theorem and so that you
now have two pairs of opposite sides
parallel and it's a parallelogram but
the key is you want you know these two
1802 180 these two add up to 180 the
consecutive angles are supplementary
okay now number 16 says which of the
following can be proved a parallelogram
okay we've got a B and C okay now we
remember we talked about some of the
properties of parallelograms earlier in
this video but
prove that a parallelogram I'm sorry
quadrilateral is a parallelogram there's
a lot of different ways to do it so
let's see if I can maybe write some of
them down here okay you can show that
both pairs of opposite sides are
parallel okay that's the definition of a
parallelogram you can also show that
both pairs of opposite sides are
congruent has to be both pairs you can
show that the diagonals they bisect each
other they cut each other in half you
can show that let's see both pairs of
opposite angles are congruent okay so
these are congruent the ones are
crossing each other can crew it again
you can show like we were doing over
here we have you know these angles are
supplementary these angles are
supplementary and here's the one that
most students tend to forget I'm sure
your teacher will probably test you on
this is that you can show that one pair
of opposite sides are both parallel and
congruent whether it's these two sides
or whether it's these two sides you show
that they're the same length and they're
parallel okay so let's take a look so
this one is what we just talked about
right here so that one can be proved
we'll just right yes okay this one
you've got one pair of opposite sides
parallel these opposite sides are
congruent but they're not the same two
sides that are parallel and congruent so
this one is no and then this one you can
see that the diagonals are cutting each
other in half this half is equal to this
half that half is equal to that half
both diagonals bisect each other so this
one is yes it can be proved a
parallelogram so these are the different
ways to prove quadrilateral is a
parallelogram number 17 it says which of
the following may not be true for a
parallelogram to be a rectangle may not
be true okay so now we're switching over
to rectangles so a parallelogram just
means that you know it has all the
properties of a parallelogram both pairs
opposite sides are congruent diagonals
are bisect each other and so forth but
in a rectangle a rectangle is a
parallelogram with the added property
that the diagonals are are the same
length okay so that's one of the
properties of rectangles so this one is
true but we're looking for which may not
be true for right angles well that's
another property of rectangles it's a
parallelogram with four right angles so
that's a rectangle okay so that's that's
not out really for the one it doesn't
work the diagonals bisect the opposite
angles well now that's true in a rhombus
the rhombus is a parallelogram
and additional properties that the
diagonals are bisecting or cutting the
opposite angles in half but that's not
necessarily true for a rectangle and one
way to kind of prove this to yourself is
to draw like a really long rectangle
like this and then draw a diagonal you
can see that this angle is much smaller
than this angle so you can see that
that's not true so that's a good counter
example so it looks like it's letter C
both check letter D opposite sides are
congruent well that's one of the
properties of a parallelogram but it
doesn't necessarily prove that it's a
rectangle so that's out so it's letter C
okay let's look at number 18 now given
isosceles trapezoid ABCD find the length
of BD okay now what's an isosceles
trapezoid
well trapezoid just to refresh means
that one pair of opposite sides are
parallel whereas a parallelogram you
have both pairs of opposite sides are
parallel but what makes it isosceles is
in addition to just having one pair of
opposite sides parallel the two legs are
the two sides are congruent and there's
all kinds of neat properties when you
have an isosceles trapezoid the base
angles are congruent see these two and
these two let's see the diagonals are
the same length okay they don't bisect
each other or cut each other in half
like in a parallelogram but they are the
same length in an isosceles trapezoid
these angles are going to be
supplementary and these two angles are
going to be supplementary because those
are consecutive interior angles so a lot
of neat properties with the trapezoids
but in this example they're giving us
this diagonal is nine which means that
we know that BD is also nine okay so
don't get distracted by some of the
other numbers here okay now number 19 it
says given trapezoid WXYZ that's this
guy here with mid segment RS is 15 X Y
is 8 find the length of wz here on the
bottom okay so what they're testing us
on in this question is the mid-segment
theorem and what the mid-segment theorem
says is that if you have a segment that
connects the two midpoints and we know
it's the midpoint because these are
congruent
these are congruent so that's a mid
segment this mid segment is the average
of the two bases so you could say base
one plus base two divided by two equals
your mid segment okay so in this case
let's move let's use that equation we're
gonna say X plus eight divided by two is
equal to 15 right multiply both sides by
2 and you get X plus 8 is e
to 30 subtract 8 from both sides and you
get X is 22 and you got it so again
remember mid-segment theorem it's like
the average of the two bases you add
those up / - that's your mid segment so
are you enjoying this video so far are
you learning something subscribe to the
channel if you haven't subscribed
already and let's keep going with this
video so it says given kite ABCD ok this
kite here it says find the measure of
angle D okay so we're talking about
kites and you know what's interesting
about a kite is that it's just like what
you think of when you think of a kite
you know you have two pairs okay of
consecutive sides congruent and you've
got you've got a line of symmetry that
goes right down the middle like this
okay so if you fold it over that line
you know this thing on this angle are
the same this singleness or you can go
the same all kinds of neat properties
about kites you know the diagonals are
perpendicular they form right angles but
again if we go to that concept of
thinking of this line here as a line of
symmetry when you fold it over see this
angle a 1/10 angle C will be exactly the
same it's also going to be 110 so in a
quadrilateral all the angles add up to
360 just like in a triangle all the
angles add up to 180 so if we add all
these up let's see what we get we get
100 200 340 and if we subtract let's see
mmm so that means that this would make
this 20 degrees because they have to add
up to 360 degrees so that's the key is
folding over that line of symmetry
you know this segment this segment are
gonna be the same you know one thing you
want to realize though is that this
diagonal when you fold it over that
diagonal that's not a line of symmetry
okay let's look at number 21 it says
what is the most specific name of
quadrilateral owl am and oh okay well
what's interesting here is that you can
see that the diagonals are bisecting
each other that proves that it's a
parallelogram but we want to get more
specific than that if possible and we
also know that if the diagonals are the
same length and it's a parallelogram
that means that it's a rectangle so the
most specific name we can go with this
one is not just parallelogram not just
quadrilateral
but rectangle and that's that's you got
it now we don't know that all the sides
are congruent so we
couldn't say that it's a square but we
definitely can say it's a rectangle so
number 22 it says a quadrilateral has
two pairs okay two pairs of consecutive
sides congruent what types of
quadrilaterals meet this condition and
there could be more than one answer
right so when they say consecutive that
means like one after another right so as
opposed to the opposite sides these are
the consecutive one after another so we
can see that it's going to be true for a
kite see a pair means these pair like
two like a pair of shoes and there's two
pairs so this is a pair this is a pair
of two pairs of consecutive sides
congruent so we know kite is one of the
answers what else well we also know
let's see how about like a rhombus a
rhombus all the sides are congruent so
you have these two pair are congruent
and these two Perrie are congruent so
that would work let's see how about for
a square same thing for a square you
know that these are the same these are
the same okay so those three would would
be be pretty good so I think that's
going to be wrap that one out and number
23 they give us this big diagram I'm
sure you're gonna have something like
this on your final exam where they're
going to have you name all the different
parts of circles and so on so let's see
if we can do this one so line a B now
notice the line above it that tells us
keeps going so a B this line a B what do
you call that what's the name for that
well you can see it just touches a
circle at one point it just touches this
circle at one point it's a tangent but
it's actually tangent to both these
circles so we would call this a common
tangent now it depends on your book but
some books will even take it one step
further and say that this is a common
external tangent internal tangent means
that would go in between the two circles
kind of like something like this okay
that would be a common internal tangent
but this is external
now segment de let's see where is that
so here's de so it starts at D ends at E
it goes through the center what's the
best name for that one diameter right
diameter okay
how about for point P let's see where is
point P let's change this to B okay so
how about for B well this B is actually
called the point of candidates
okay point of tangency that's the point
where the line just barely touches the
circle at that one point so point of
tangency would be the best one there
segment EF okay that's from here to here
that's a chord now remember this problem
we did with the diameter this is also a
chord it's the longest chord in a circle
but because it goes through the center
we call that a diameter line tu let's
see where is that tu okay
it keeps going it's not like a chord
where it starts at T and ends at you it
keeps going and cuts through the circle
at two points that's actually called a
secant right Seca NT secant right
segment Cee that starts at the center
ends at the point on the circle that's a
radius right radius Point C that's the
center of the circle so I'll just write
Center okay and that's it you got it so
that's naming the different parts of a
circle now for number 24 it says L is a
point of tangency okay this is point L
right here this is M this is n so it's a
point of tangency find the radius acts
that length okay now what's interesting
is when you draw a radius to the point
of tangency what kind of angle is formed
right here a right angle right now
what's also interesting here and they
don't draw this on the diagram but you
see how this is X and this is also going
to be ax because these are both radii
from here to here is the radius from the
center to this point on the circle
that's a radius but now notice what we
have coming into view here that's a
right triangle and we know that we have
a right triangle we can use Pythagorean
theorem so let's go ahead and set that
up so we've got a squared plus B squared
equals C squared remember the one across
from the right angle that's our C side
so we've got x squared plus 12 squared
equals ax plus 8 squared I had to add
these two together to get that total
lengths we want to square that quantity
now here's where students go off the
track and I don't want you to go off
track here what the students will do is
they'll just distribute that to now you
can't do that because this is a binomial
you actually have to foil this out so
it's really going to be like X plus 8
times another X plus 8 and if you foil
that out you get x squared plus 16 X
plus 64 equals x squared plus 144 now if
you subtract x squared from both sides
those cancel out if you subtract 64 from
144 you get 80 equals 16x and if you
divide both sides by 16
you can see that X is going to be equal
to five and that's your radius
okay everybody hanging in there this is
a good review we're covering a lot of
important concepts so in this problem
number 25 what we have is we've got a
point outside the circle right and
you've got two tangents drawn to the
circle and what do you know when you
have a point outside the circle and two
tangents drawn to the circle one above
one below well we know that those two
lengths are going to be congruent now
this one means or asks us to find the
length of a B right but what we have to
do is we have to set these equal to each
other first to find out what x equals
okay
lot of times students saw and they find
out what X is but they don't take it one
step further and put it back in to find
the length of a B so let's solve this
we're going to subtract 3x from both
sides we're gonna add two to both sides
we're gonna divide by two x equals five
some students will mistakenly put five
but what you want to do is want to put
it back in here that's going to be three
times 5 15 plus 2 is 17 you can double
check it 25 minus 8 is 17 so you can see
both of those tangents are the same
length okay number 26 they give us a
circle here and it asks us to find the
measure of let's see measure of angle C
this is actually should be the measure
of Arc AC okay that's the measure
meaning how many degrees is that arc now
notice there's only two points here that
means that this is a minor arc which
means we know that it's gonna be less
than 180 but what's interesting is if
they give us the central angle 50 that
arc that it intercepts is also going to
have a measure of 50 so that's the
central angle this angle and this arc
measure are going to be the same so
that's going to be 50 degrees now the
measure of let's see arc lem okay so
where is our km so that's here to here
to here okay so notice it's going to be
it's a major arc or a semi circle when
you have three letters like that and
it's telling you to go from L to M
through point a in between LM but one
thing you want to notice here is that if
this angle is 40 to see how these two
form in axes to line segments these two
cords the angles across from each other
those are going to be congruent those
are vertical angles and so what we can
do is we can say this is like a diameter
so I'm going a hundred and eighty
degrees plus an additional forty degrees
that's 220 degrees
okay and then the measure of Arc C II
that's this guy right here
well again you can see that this is a
diameter okay le if this adds up to 90
that means that this must add up this
must be 90 because they have to have to
180 degrees because that's straight
angle so the measure of Arc seee will be
the same as that central angle 90
degrees and you got it so again what I
recommend when they give you a diagram
like this you know is jump into the
diagram try to fill out what you know
you know and then you can go back and
then this will make it a little bit
easier so you not to remember it all in
your head okay number 27 another circle
diagram and let's see it says the
measure of Arc X Z okay and the measure
of Arc TZ are the same okay so they're
saying that this arc and this arc are
the same length now when you see that
the arcs are the same length that means
that the cords that intercept those arcs
will also be congruent and vice versa if
the cords are congruent then the arcs
that they intercept are congruent does
that make sense
so now we say if XY is equal to 4 so if
this is 4 right here right then what's
the length of TZ well here's what's
interesting when you draw a radius
perpendicular to that chord it's gonna
bisect the chord okay so that means this
is 4 which means that this whole chord
is 8 this chord will also be 8 ok good
now let's see over here it says if the
measure of Arc XZ equals 150 okay now
I'm just gonna erase these we're gonna
start fresh on this problem so if this
is 150 find the measure of Arc X T well
remember if these arcs are congruent
that's 150 that's 150 how much is this
arc right here all the arcs in a circle
add up to 360 degrees right so this is
300 that means that this must be 60
because they have to add up to 360 and
in Part C says if W y equals x plus 1
okay so this little piece right here X
plus 1 and W are this little piece right
here is 2x minus 3 find the length of W
R now here's the thing if they let me
see I can draw a little picture here
basically inner I'll draw it right here
so basically if the chords are the same
length
okay what that means is that they're the
same
distance from the center a perpendicular
distance the shortest distance so that's
the idea so because we know that these
arcs are the same we know that the
chords that intercept those arcs are
congruent if the chords are this
congruent that means they're the same
distance from the center so all we have
to do is set these equal to each other
so let me do that right here so 2x minus
3 equals x plus 1 subtract x add 3 you
can see x equals 4 and if we put that
back in that's going to be 2 times 4 is
8 minus 3 is 5 and you can double-check
it you know that's going to be 4 plus 1
is 5 right okay so very good problem
number 28 it says if a B is equal to 8
so they're saying the length of this
chord is 8 and FD is 3 okay that's
that's right here this is 3 find the
radius of circle D okay this is circle D
okay now this is very interesting
because you see how they're drawing this
diameter perpendicular to this chord
that means that it cuts the cord in half
okay bisects the chord it also bisects
this arc over here okay so that means
that if a B is 8 that means that this
length right here is 4 this length over
here is 4 now what it wants is the
radius of the circle which would be like
de they don't draw it in the picture but
what you can do is you can draw what
they call an auxilary line you know you
draw on your own line from D to B for
example now look what we have we've got
a right triangle also Pythagorean triple
3 4 5 so the radius is going to be 5
okay so see how I did that so remember
the diameter that's perpendicular to the
chord it cuts the cord in half it
bisects it okay it's at a right angle
here we just had to draw on that line
and do the Pythagorean theorem and we
got it okay number 29 what we have is we
have two chords that intersect and what
happens when they intersect is they
divide each other into two parts or two
pieces right our two segments and what's
interesting is is that the product of
these two segments is equal to the
product of these two segments so 4 times
X is equal to 3 times 8 which is 24
divided by 4 X is equal to 6 okay so
you're with me on that one so another
way to to write it a lot of times when I
explain this to students I say well just
think of this as a and B this is C and D
a times B equals C times D
and that's the property okay number 30
it says find ax okay so what we have
here is we have to seek ins okay it's
cutting through the circle at two points
and what you want to do for this one is
you want to take the whole length okay
which is going to be 8 times the
external portion the part outside the
circle equals this whole length which is
X plus 4 times the part outside the
circle so we I always like to explain it
to students when I'm tutoring them as I
say whole times external equals whole
times external it's easy to remember
right so now let's just simplify let's
do the algebra so that's going to be 24
equals 4x plus 16 I'm just doing the
distributive property and if you
subtract 16 from both sides okay you've
got that and if you divide by a 4 you
can see that X is equal to 2 it wants to
know if the lengths of X we put that
back in that's to my drawings not
drawing to scale but sometimes that's
how it works
my mario's math tutoring YouTube channel
I've got a playlist a geometry playlist
which has a lot of different videos
covering all different aspects of
geometry so if you're looking for
additional help beyond this video you
can go over there and check out that
playlist to go through it and see what
other topics you want to learn more
about but let's keep going with this so
number 31 what they're giving us here is
they're giving us a secant and they're
giving us a tangent so remember the form
that I remember in the last problem we
did the whole times the external equals
whole times external well in this case
we're going to take the whole times the
external equals the tangent squared okay
so that's the key so the whole length
here is 9 the external part meaning the
part outside the circle is 4 equals the
tangent times the tangent or the tangent
squared so we get x squared is equal to
36 take the square root of both sides
and you can see x equals 6 okay number
32 what they have here is they're giving
us an inscribed quadrilateral subscribe'
means to draw a right in means on the
inside the vertices are just barely
touching the edges of the circle but
what's interesting in this scenario is
that the angles that are opposite one
another are supplementary okay meaning
they add up to 180 so here what we can
do is we can solve some equations we can
say well mmmm let's see we want to solve
for x and y so 110 plus x equals 180 so
that means that x equals 70
and over here we have y minus 5 plus 92
equals a 180 so let's write that
equation y minus 5 plus 92 equals 180 so
let's see that comes out to what 87 all
right subtract the 87 and what does that
come out choose at 93 yeah 93 okay so
that was a good one so opposite angles
are supplementary
number 33 it says find the measure of
Arc X Z so we're trying to find out how
many degrees is this arc right here okay
well now what's interesting here is
we're starting to get into you know some
other problems there with circles but
what you have is this formula here us if
I can kind of show you what you have is
you have an external angle exterior
angle this angle one and what you do is
you take these two arcs that it cuts off
or intercepts I'm going to call this arc
a and this arc be the measure of angle 1
is equal to a minus B divided by 2 okay
so it's the larger arc minus the smaller
arc divided by 2 equals 1/6 earier angle
the only problem is is that let's go
ahead and call this arc right here X
since that's what we're trying to solve
for that means that this arc over here
must be 180 not 180 360 minus X right
because they all have to add up to 360
so now what we're gonna do is going to
take this larger arc which is X minus
the smaller arc which is 360 minus X all
divided by 2 equals the 60 angle which
is 48 degrees ok so you're with me so
now what we're gonna do is we're going
to multiply both sides by 2 to get rid
of the fraction here I'm going to
distribute the negative so that's going
to be negative 360 plus X so now we have
2x minus 360 equals 96 add the 360 to
the other side which equals how much
let's see that be what is it 456 456 and
then divide both sides by 2 and the X is
equal to 228 so check my math on that
one if I'm wrong put a note in the
comment sections for other people that
watch this video but that should be
right so basically you're taking the
larger arc minus the smaller arc divided
by 2 equals the exterior angle now we're
getting into the equation of a
Circle and the standard form for the
equation of a circle is this guy right
here it's X minus H squared plus y minus
K squared is equal to the radius squared
H comma K is the center and then R is
the radius so in this case all we have
to do is substitute we've got X minus a
negative 3 which is like X plus 3 and y
minus positive 1 so Y minus 1 squared
and 5 is the radius so we square that 5
squared is 25 so that's the equation of
our circle in the standard form of the
equation of a circle
number 35 it gives us the point 1
negative 9 is on a circle with the
center at 4 negative 5 right the
standard equation of the circle so a
little bit of different variation here
the center is at 4 negative 5 so that's
X minus 4 squared plus y plus 5 squared
equals the radius squared one thing
you'll notice is that these numbers here
are always the opposite sign right so
this is actually a positive 4 negative 5
see the center because you're
subtracting but what we have to do is we
have to find out what R squared is here
to complete this equation but they give
us a hint they tell us at the point 1
negative 9 is on the circle so I'm gonna
put one in for X negative 9 in for y and
then we can solve for R squared so 1
minus 4 is negative 3 negative 3 squared
is 9 negative 9 plus 4 is negative 4
negative 4 square root of 16 so you can
see that R squared is equal to 25 all we
have to do is put that back in and we've
got our equation now that's one way to
do it the other way to do it is you can
do the distance formula ok and find the
distance from the center to the point
that's your radius then just put it in
here and square it and that's that's
your equation okay number 36 it says
find the area of the parallelogram well
what's the formula the area of a
parallelogram is just base times height
so here's the base and the height is
this perpendicular distance between the
two opposite sides the two bases so this
is going to be 6 times 3 which is just
18 centimeters squared
they put this 4 on here to test you you
know so nice to distract you a little
bit some people might think 6 times 4
that would be fine if it was a rectangle
like length times width or base times
height but here what we want is that
perpendicular height okay now number 37
they give us a triangle perimeter and
area of the triangle now remember
earlier in this video we were talking
about Pythagorean triples and as you
work with Pythagorean triples more and
more these will start to jump out at you
so we know seven 2425 forms a right
triangle that's the Pythagorean triple
if we double all these we get 14 48 and
50 so you say oh well that means this
must be 48 then 14 48 and 50 okay so now
if we want to find the perimeter we just
have to add up all the sides that's the
distance all the way around so what does
that come out to that's 98 that would
give us 1o 212 right so 112 inches and
then the area of a triangle remember
it's 1/2 base times height this is the
base that's the bottom that's what it
sits on that's the height that's how
tall it is the triangles like a mountain
right so you measure straight down so
that's going to be 1/2 48 times 14 right
now you can multiply these in any order
I'm gonna do 1/2 times 14 is 7 then I
just have to figure out what 48 times 7
is sometimes your teacher has no
calculator section so let's see that
would be 28 plus 5 which gives you 33 so
this would be three hundred and thirty
six inches squared and you can check my
work on that one or you can check it on
your calculator real quick here I'll
just double check make sure we got the
right answer
336 ok cruising right along number 38 it
says the area of the trapezoid is 36
meters squared find X so what they're
testing us out of this question is do we
remember the formula for the area of a
trapezoid and I'll just write it down
here for us so it's 1/2 the height which
is for cadets the distance between the
two bases times base 1 which is X plus
base 2 which is 12 so the bases of the
two parallel sides now they tell us that
the area is 36 so I'll put that in there
so all we have to do is simplify so we
get 1/2 of 4 is 2 divide both sides by 2
that gives you 18 equals x plus 12
subtract 12 from both sides and you can
see that X is equal to 6 meters and make
sure you put your units if there's units
in the problem right number 39 it's
talking about the area of a rhombus now
the nice thing about rhombus and kite is
that they have the same area formula so
it's one last thing to remember eyes
I just have to remember area equals
one-half diagonal 1 times diagonal 2 so
in this case they're only giving us this
pieces 2 but in a rhombus
we know that the diagonals bisect each
other so this is actually going to be a
length of 6 the other diagonal is a
length of 4 and we do 1/2 6 times 4 so
let's see that's 24 half of 24 is 12
units squared okay number 40 it says
that the area of a kite is 72
centimeters squared and one diagonal is
24 centimeters what is the length of the
other diagonal well again remember it's
the same formula for roundness and kite
so let's put in what we know I like to
write down my formula first and then
write underneath it I like to substitute
in what I know and then I can always
solve for what I don't know I'll just
put that X for diagonal 2 so 1/2 of 24
is 12 divide both sides by 12 you can
see that X is equal to 6 and in this
case it's centimeters okay number 41
they're giving us two similar polygons
now remember similar polygons the
corresponding angles are congruent but
the corresponding sides are proportional
right and it says a and B they have a
scale factor of 2 2 3 ok they give us
the perimeter in the area of the smaller
one they want us to find the perimeter
in the area of the larger one well
here's the thing if you know that the
scale factor is 2 to 3 the ratios of the
perimeters see perimeters just like
lengths will be the same as the ratio of
the side blanks so it's also going to
have a ratio of 2 to 3 so if the
perimeter of the smaller one is 25 we
can solve for the perimeter of the
larger one now notice when I set up it's
proportionate I did small to large C 2
is smaller than 3 so small to large
I did the perimeter of the small figure
2 the large figure C small to large
small to large you want to keep that
consistent then you cross multiply on
the diagonal right so a to P equals 75
divided by 2 that's 37 point 5 whatever
the units are will just say units now
for a for the area here's where students
sometimes get a little bit off-track if
the scale factor is 2 2 3 right 2 2 3
you have to square that to get the ratio
of the areas if it was a 3 dimensional
figure you would
cube the scale factor to get the ratio
of the volumes so if we Square this we
square the numerator in the denominator
that's going to give you a 4 to 9 ratio
and the area of the smaller one is 43 we
just have to find the area of the larger
one see small to large small the large
cross multiply on the diagonal we get 4x
equals 9 times 43 so I'm gonna go to the
calculator here just to make sure I
don't make a little arithmetic error
that's 387 and we just divide both sides
by 4 and that comes out to 96.7 5 units
squared since its area okay now number
42 what we want to do is find the area
of this octagon notice it's a regular
octagon all the sides are congruent and
it looks like a stop sign right but
remember when you find the area of a
regular polygon this is the form that
you want to memorize 1/2 apothem times
perimeter ok the perimeter is easy to
figure out you just add up all the sides
in this case is 10 times 8 okay which is
going to be 80 but the apothem what's
that okay it's kind of a weird kind of
name but what it is it's the
perpendicular distance from the center
to the side now what happens when you
draw that perpendicular is it bisects
the side it cuts it in half and so now
each of these are going to be 5 but what
we have to do now is we have to find out
what that central angle is well the
thing is you can divide up an octagon in
two if we can draw this for us here
whoops I'm missing I'm missing the
vertices here you can draw out like this
you can divide it up into eight
congruent triangles so if you take 360
divided by 8 that gives you the central
angle of 45 degrees so that's the same
right here but then if we bisect it
we're cutting it in half so let's see if
I can draw this trying a little bit
larger for us so we can see what what
this looks like so this was originally
45 we bisected it that means that this
is twenty two point five this is our
apothem it's the height of the triangle
and this is five okay so what we're
gonna do now is we're going to ask
ourself what trig function ties together
this angle this side and this side we've
got opposite and we have adjacent that's
tangent right so the tangent of 22.5
equals opposite over adjacent I can
cross multiply a times the tangent of
22.5 equals five times one which is five
divide both sides by the tan of 22.5
right like that both sides and let's see
what that comes out to you so 5 divided
by the tan 22.5 it's 12 point zero seven
okay if I round and all we have to do
now is multiply all that together so if
I do that twelve point zero seven times
0.5 times 80 it looks like I'm getting
four hundred eighty two point eight four
hundred eighty two point eight units
squared so remember the formula for a
regular polygon one-half apothem times
perimeter so if you like my teaching
style and you're preparing for the AC T
or the SAT the math sections check out
my two courses my huge AC t-- math
review video course and a huge SAT math
review video course I go through a
teaching section we go through example
problems we go through formulas we go
through different ways to approach the
problems and recognize the problems so
when you take that task you're gonna be
better prepared to score well so there's
three free lessons in each of those
courses that you can take and get some
experience with the course benefit from
that and if you want to go further get
the courses and a lot of students have
already taken the courses and reported
back that they've improved their scores
I'm sure you will too so check those out
if you're interested in private tutoring
with me I have a busy schedule you know
working with in-person students but I do
have some online students and if I have
availability I'd be happy to help you
weather prepare for the AC T SAT or you
know your math class a final whatever it
is that you're working on feel free to
reach out to me
also check out more math videos on my
youtube channel I've got a ton of
information there that can benefit you
as well but let's keep going with this
video and make sure that you're ready
for your geometry final so number
forty-three they're giving us a circle
and they're asking us for the
circumference in the area so there's a
lot of formulas you know on math that
you have to memorize in this case you
know the circumference is pi times
diameter or you could say 2 pi r in this
case since they're giving us the
diameter is 12 I'm just gonna say 12 pi
that's an exact answer and that's going
to be meters now if you wanted to round
to the nearest tenth or hundredth then I
would put in 3.14 4 pi and multiply area
and now the formula for area you want to
memorize is PI R squared and I think of
a circle as like a pizza pie like you
know apple pie pies are square no
they're actually round right
but here what we have to do is you have
to cut the diner in half to get a radius
of 6 and then do PI times 6 squared
which is 36 PI and then it's going to be
meters squared since its area okay
number 44 they want us to find the
length of our KB not the measure the
measure would be 120 degrees with the
actual length if you were to straighten
that out and they want us to find the
area of the sector
okay so length of a B first well there's
a couple different ways to do this
problem I'm going to show you this way
first 120 divided by 360 okay
that's the fraction of this angle to the
whole circle 360 equals the arc length
which I'm just going to say arc is to
the entire circumference which is 2 PI R
which in this case would be 8 pi 2 times
pi times 4 then all you have to do is
cross multiply and solve what you might
want to do first is reduce this this
reduces to 1/3 then when you cross
multiply you get 3 I'm just gonna say a
for arc length equals 1 times 8 pi
divide everything by 3 and so you're
getting 8 thirds pi inches okay that's
an exact answer if you want an
approximation put in 3.14 now for the
area of the sector you can do the same
thing make a proportion the other way to
do it is though you can say 120 divided
by 360 is 1/3 so we're actually taking
1/3 of PI R squared PI R squared is the
whole circle we just want the fraction
of the whole circle of means x right so
this is 16 pi times 1/3 which is 16
thirds PI inches squared that's an exact
answer okay number 45 it says how many
vertices does a pentagonal pyramid have
well let's see if we can draw it so
basically a pentagonal pyramid means it
has a base that's a Pentagon right and
it goes to a vertex up here so the
vertices are the the points it's where
the edges come together so I'm counting
1 2 3 4 5 6 there's six vertices six
points ok the edges would be like these
segments okay and the faces would be
they in this case the triangles and the
Pentagon's the polygons that make up the
three-dimensional figure number 46 it
says which are polyhedrons poly means
many and Hedra means like you know sides
or faces right but the thing is in order
for to be a polyhedron you know a
3-dimensional polyhedron
all the faces all the sides have to be
made up of polygons what's a polygon a
polygon is an enclosed region okay one
enclosed region that it's made up of
line segments so for example I drew a
Pentagon here but I could have drawn a
square I could have drawn a triangle for
example like this that's not a polygon
see it's enclosing two different regions
this is not a polygon because you can
see there's a curved region right here
so this one you can see the circle
that's not a polygon so this is not a
polyhedron this one's a triangular prism
this one is yes this one is a square
pyramid or a rectangular pyramid so this
one is yes you can see all the faces are
triangles or squares so these are
polyhedrons now 47 says given a
polyhedron with eight faces and four
vertices how many edges does it have now
what they're testing us on this question
is do we remember Euler's formula okay
orders Formosa or Euler's formula how do
you want to pronounce it now the way I
remember this formulas it's my favorite
formula my fav right fve my favorite
formula faces plus vertices equals edges
plus two now the number of faces here
are eight the number of vertices are
four we don't know the number of edges
but we can simplify this 12 equals e
plus 2 subtract 2 there's 10 edges ok so
just remember Euler's formula f plus V
equals E Plus 2 number 48 what is the
shape of the cross section of a plane
cutting through a cone of parallel to
its base well let's see if we can draw a
cone there is a cone a plane is like a
flat surface it cuts through parallel to
the to the base which is a circle looks
like we get another circle now sometimes
what you're going to get on your test is
you might get like for example if it
cuts through the vertex perpendicular to
the base then you would get like a
triangle okay so it depends on what
angle if you go on a diagonal like this
you would get like an ellipse or an oval
you know and so on and so forth but
basically it's good to draw a diagram
and then visualize what's happening with
that one so let's go on to the next
question okay we're getting near the end
just a few more problems to go if this
is benefitting you let me know how you
did on your final exam report back to
this video comment section below I love
to hear how you know students you know
benefited from these different videos
that I put together so I know to make
more and just let me know in the
comments that
be great number 49 says the scale factor
between two similar figures is three to
five if the smaller figure has a volume
of 81 inches cubed more does the volume
of the larger figure well we talked a
little bit about this earlier about
scale factor between you know the side
lengths and the surface areas and the
volumes what you want to do is you want
to take that scale factor three to five
three to five and because it's volume
you want to cube it so it's really going
to be a ratio of 27 to a hundred and
twenty-five small to large right so in
this case the smaller figure has a
volume of 81 we want to find the volume
of the larger figure so small the large
small to large the key was we had to do
this operation of cubing the scale
factor to get the ratio of the volumes
now we can make a proportion here you
can cross multiply and solve or here's
another little technique 27 times 3 is
81 so if I multiply the numerator by 3 I
have to multiply the denominator by 3
that's going to be 125 times 3 which is
375 inches cubed okay let's go to number
50 now so 50 what I did is I put
together a diagram like this to kind of
illustrate how this works with a scale
factor see scale factor you're comparing
like the side lengths or the perimeters
or one-dimensional components okay of
the figures area you're comparing like
lateral area surface area
two-dimensional components volume you're
looking at three-dimensional components
right so the key is are we're dealing
with one two or three dimensions so if
the scale factor is one to two and
you're going from one-dimensional or
two-dimensional you have to square this
so that's going to be 1 squared is 1 2
squared is 4 if you want to go from the
scale factor which is one-dimensional to
the volume which is 3 dimensional you
have to cube this scale factor 1 cubed
is 1 2 cubed is 8 so you're with me so
far
but if they give you the ratio of the
area's that's two-dimensional you want
to go back to one dimensional you have
to square root so that's going to be
square root of 9 is 3 squared of 25 is 5
now if you want to go from one
dimensional a three-dimensional surface
scale factor to volume we have to cube
both of these that's 27 to 125 and then
here if they give us the volume
3-dimensional we want to go back to the
one-dimensional components we have to
take the cube roots to go from 3 to 1
cube root of 64 is 4 square root of 729
I believe is nine let me just double
check really quick nine cubed
yeah 729 that's right now if we want to
go from the scale factor to the ratio
the area is one to two we have to square
this which is going to be 16 to 81 so
that's how you work back and forth you
know you just have to analyze it is it
one two or three dimensional and you
know work from there but it's easier to
go back to the scale factor first then
square it to get the ratio of the areas
or the volumes okay let's go to number
51 51 has four parts we're finding
surface area and volume of these
three-dimensional figures so here's the
thing we've got a cylinder the cylinder
the formula is for surface area it's to
be two bases plus the perimeter of the
base or the circumference of the base
times the height so the base is a circle
so we have two PI R squared plus the
perimeter their circumference is 2 PI R
times the height so if we put in
everything we get 2 pi times 5 squared
which is 25 plus 2 pi the radius is 5
the height is 10 we get 50 pi plus 50
times 2 is a hundred pi so we're getting
a hundred and 50 PI inches squared for
the surface area the total area of the
outside the volume the formulas a little
bit easier it's the area of the base
times the height so the base is a circle
so PI R squared times the height so it's
pi times 5 squared times the height is
10 so that's 25 times 10 is 250 times pi
inches cube so these are exact answers
if you want to find a rounded answer
just put 3.14 and 4 pi now for letter B
they're giving us a triangular and I'm
sorry a square pyramid right the base is
a square okay so to find the surface
area you have to find the area of one
base not two bases like well here we had
two just one base plus one half the
perimeter of the base times the slant
height the L of a leaning height well
they give us the leaning height is five
here so that's the height of this
triangle right here that's five they
give us the perimeter of the base which
is six times four so that's 24 times a
half and then the base here is six times
six it's a square that's 36 so if we add
this together that's half of 24 is 12 12
times 5 is 60 plus 36 gives us 96 units
square
now if we want to find the volume the
volume is the area of the base times the
height times one-third now when we're
looking at the volume we want this
height here the one from the vertex to
the middle of the base not the slant
height we use that owl that leaning
height that slant height for the surface
area so here we're news take the area of
the base which we figured out was 36 6
times 6 times 1/3 times the height now I
drew my drawing a little bit small here
so bear with me the key here is you want
to draw in this auxilary line you see
how there's a triangle being formed here
you've got five which is the slant
height like this right this is going to
the center so it's half of the side
length it's half of six which is three
and we're looking for this height which
is right here H you can see this is a 3
4 5 right triangle or you can do
Pythagorean theorem the height here is 4
so half of 36 is 12 I'm sorry one third
of 36 is 12 times 4 is 48 units cubed
since it's volume okay number letters
see I should say we want to find surface
area and volume of this pentagonal prism
okay the top and bottom are Pentagon's
they're separated by the height let's
just make this height 10 okay so the
surface area would be what it's going to
be two bases plus the perimeter of the
base times the height let's do this part
first so the perimeter is 4 times 5
which is 20 times the height which is 10
okay which just comes out to 200 but now
the base you see it's a regular polygon
it's a regular pentagon so this is
actually going to be one half the
apothem times the perimeter two times
one half that cancels so we just have to
do the apothem which they give us which
is 2.75 times the perimeter which is 4
times 5 which is 20 okay so now if we do
all this together what do we get we get
2 times let's see that's 27.5 doubled
which is 55 so this is comes out to 255
for the surface area units squared and
if we want the volume we have to take
the area of the base times the height so
it's easy to find the volume of a prism
area of the base one-half of pathum
times perimeter times the height which
is 10 let's see the apothem we know is
2.75 the perimeter we know is 4 times 5
which is 25 sides so let's see we get
200
times 1/2 which is 100 which would give
you 275 units cubed for the volume okay
now for letter D we've got a sphere and
the surface area for a sphere is what 4
PI R squared the volume is 4/3 PI R
cubed so sometimes students get these
little bit confused but remember cubed
is 3 dimensional squared is
two-dimensional that's area cubed is 3 D
that's volume right so really there's
only one dimension here there's just the
radius which is 3 so put that in there 3
squared is 9 times 4 is 36 PI ok units
squared since is an area 3 cubed is 27
here let me write this out 4/3 PI times
27 the 3 and the 27 you can reduce so
that also comes out to 36 pi but now
this is units cubed they don't always
work out to be the same like that in
this particular case they did but the
dimensions are different this is units
Square this is units cubed for volume ok
let's go to the next question
okay homestretch number 52 it says draw
a net for a square pyramid so we know
what a square pyramid looks like it has
a base that's a square right
he has triangles for sides if you unfold
this here's your square base and then
you've got four triangles coming off the
sides so that's your net you're laying
it flat
you're unfolding it okay number 53 it
says how many planes of symmetry does a
cone have okay well we know what a cone
looks like right and symmetry means it's
the same so if you take a plane and you
cut through this how many ways can you
cut through it in such a way that each
side you know is a mirror image of the
other side right well if you if you
think about looking at a cone from above
from the sky see you could cut it like
this right through the vertex you're
kind of like this like this like this
infinite number of ways so in this case
there's an infinite number of planes of
symmetry with a regular hexagonal prism
though what this means is that you have
two bases which are hexagons right
something like this okay and so what you
could do here is again if you look from
above you can say that there's a how
many planes of symmetry well you can see
it could go like for example like this
like this like this or through the
corners for five
six and you might stop there and say six
but you could also draw one right like
this if you're cutting it in half so
there's gonna be seven planes of
symmetry where it's going to be a mirror
image on either side
number of fifty-four says what is it
probably that you pick a red marble set
it aside then you pick another red
marble from this hat you mix them all up
your blindfold you reach in what's the
problem you pick a red marble you set it
aside you pick another red marble well
there's three red to blue so the
probability of picking a red is three
out of five for the first one now I'll
say you pick that red marble what's the
chance of picking another one two
chances of success out of four total and
you multiply those together so remember
probability it's the number of successes
out of the total possible outcomes but
then it changes with a second draw
because this is without replacement the
key words to pay attention to with
replacement if you put it back in it
would be three out of five again without
replacement you have to consider the new
probability so if we multiply these
together we get six over twenty six over
twenty if we reduced that we get three
tenths so that's your probability last
question number 55 in your school of two
thousand students three hundred run
track 150 play soccer 75 do both what is
the probability that a student picked at
random doesn't play either so what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna draw a Venn
diagram okay so here's all the people
that run track here's all the people to
play soccer here's the 75 people that do
both see that's in the overlapping
region so if there's a total of let's
see how many play tracked three hundred
that means there's 225 that run track
but don't play soccer right on the 150
people that play soccer 75 you both
seventy-five just play soccer now here's
the thing if you add up all these
students what are we getting we're
getting three hundred and seventy-five
right but we said there was two thousand
total in the entire school so what's
2,000 minus 375
it's 2,000 minus 3 75 that's 16 25 right
so that means there's 16 hundred and 25
outside of these sets and the
probability that we pick somebody at
random from the outside you know that
they don't play these sports is going to
be 1625 chances of success out of the
2,000 total students so that's your
probability and you can reduce that down
let's see what that
comes out to thirteen sixteenths would
be your probability so equals thirteen
sixteenth so I hope this video helps you
boost your score on your geometry final
exam or if you're just reviewing
geometry I hope it helped you to review
these important concepts subscribe to
the channel check out more math videos
on geometry if you're interested on my
youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
reach out to me if you have questions or
comments or you want to do some tutoring
or you want to have access to some of my
courses I look forward to helping you in
the future videos and I'll talk to you
soon